I think studying disease is not a great way
to learn how to be healthy.
The best treatment is actually to create health.
We need to stop fixating on the study of disease
and start studying the science of creating health.
Hello, everybody.
This is Dr. Kempley Connors.
Welcome to another episode of Cutters Clinic Live.
We have a great guest today, Ari Whitton,
who does a lot of work with energy
and increasing people's energy.
And we got a lot to talk about the short times
who are going to jump right into it and welcome to our show.
Thank you so much for having me.
It's a pleasure.
So we're not going to dig deep into your history.
We'll let people discover that on your website.
We'll have all that information.
But let's talk about what your passion is in helping people.
The very short version of it for me
is I've been studying health science since I was a little kid.
Since I was 12 years old, this health science,
fitness, athletic performance, body composition,
being healthy, what it means to be healthy and live a long life
has really been at the center of my existence and my world,
my world mentally.
This is what I've been studying pretty much my whole life.
I'm going to be three decades now pretty soon.
I'm turning 40 this year.
And the initial portion of my study
was very much dedicated to athletic performance
and body building and body composition.
And that was my world for a very long time.
I was very dedicated to it.
I was very gifted in that area.
By the time I was 14 years old,
I was reading college-level textbooks on nutrition
and exercise physiology and things like that.
And I think that also gave me a really unique
background.
My older brother, who we were just talking about,
who's a chiropractor, was my best friend from a very young age.
He was also dedicated to health.
He was a body builder and personal trainer
from the time I was very young and being
mentored by a professional body builder.
And so I had this introduction from a very young age
to that world, which was really biohacking
before biohacking was a term.
The original biohackers were body builders.
And this kind of knowledge is a very unique kind of knowledge
because it's experiential.
It's not sitting in a classroom learning abstract concepts
about health and biochemistry and different mechanisms.
It is literally the day-to-day constant experimentation
with your own physiology.
Basically, I went on to do a degree in kinesiology,
exercise science, a lot of focus on nutrition,
got certifications in nutrition.
And as a performance enhancement specialist,
the corrective exercise specialist,
training and being a nutritionist working
with individuals was my day-to-day operation
and experimentation, not only at that point
with my own physiology but with many, many other people.
And then I actually went to medical school for a couple years,
hated it, went to a PhD program in clinical psychology,
completed all three years of coursework,
and then really decided I want to move back to my roots
in nutrition and exercise and lifestyle choices to be healthy.
And I've also done a master's in human nutrition
and functional medicine.
I think this base of experimentation
with human physiology is really important.
And I would also add, there's a really interesting distinction
between a focus on pathology and disease
versus a focus on health.
And the whole conventional medical paradigm, certainly,
is really a disease paradigm.
It's a pathology paradigm.
It's the study of disease.
And the whole paradigm is sort of based
on a conceptual framework that says,
if we study the biochemical mechanisms of disease,
we can figure out, quote unquote, the cause of the disease,
for example, depression is caused by a,
caused quote unquote by a deficiency in serotonin in the brain
or atherosclerosis and heart disease is caused by LDL cholesterol
and so on and so forth.
And then based on that understanding of pathology,
it seeks to create drugs that interrupt what it perceives
to be abnormal physiology, to interrupt
those disease processes.
And then by virtue of interrupting abnormal biochemical
mechanisms that are associated with disease,
the idea is that would reverse the disease
or cure the disease or at least hopefully correct
some of the symptoms of it.
And there's a context where that model works really well
in battlefield medicine and wartime medicine
and even in the context of emergency medicine
and dealing with acute infections.
It can be antibiotics, can be life saving.
But when it comes to chronic disease,
the model has really been a massive failure.
And what I think is that it's been a failure largely
because of the focus on disease.
I think studying disease is not a great way
to learn how to be healthy.
It's different sets of tools.
And if we want to be healthy and prevent disease
and I would argue in most cases the best treatment
for most diseases was some exceptions,
the best treatment is actually to create health.
And so the whole paradigm needs to be upended.
If we actually want to create health,
we need to stop fixating on the study of disease
and start studying the science of creating health.
We're looking at it completely backwards
what you're saying.
Yeah.
So how do you, you get an average person
that maybe has some sort of autoimmune disease
or something like that?
How do you get them from that medical model
into a more functional health lifestyle model
that it's an educational process, isn't it?
It is.
Yeah. And here's a big shift in thinking.
This is really interesting.
I find a lot of people don't know this.
I've been shocked actually also
at the amount of practitioners that don't know this.
But it's really important.
You're kind of extending out from what I was just talking about.
There's a lot of research to show that even if we,
well actually let me step back for a second.
So the whole central core Western medical paradigm is
we need to, there's this disease
and there's that disease, heart disease
and cancer, neurological disease
and obesity and diabetes.
And if only we could find cures for these diseases.
And the assumption built into this
is that if we had a cure for heart disease,
if we had a cure for cancer, et cetera,
that we would just live so much longer.
And in fact, this paradigm is completely not true.
This assumption is totally wrong.
It's actually been shown in numerous studies
that if we had a cure for heart disease tomorrow,
heart disease is the number one killer in the Western world.
If we had a cure for it tomorrow,
it would actually barely budge the average lifespan.
The same is true for cancer, the same is true
for all the other major diseases
that we are desperately in search of a cure for.
And the reason why is that these are largely diseases
of lifestyle and environment that are,
it's not just one part of the body
that has some kind of dysfunction.
It's widespread dysfunctional physiology
and poor metabolic health,
that's creating dysfunction in numerous systems of the body.
And then basically the diagnosis of what disease you get
is essentially whatever disease process happens
to emerge first, sort of based on your weakest link.
But it's not like if you remove that piece,
the rest of you is completely healthy
and is gonna live a much longer period of time.
In fact, the research shows that basically
if somebody didn't die of heart disease at age 79,
they'd probably die of cancer at age 80.
And if they didn't die of cancer at age 80,
they'd die of complications from diabetes
or neurological disease at age 80 and a half or 81.
And if all of those diseases are cured,
it would still barely budge the average lifespan
because most people's whole body essentially breaks down.
You get multi organ failure on average by about age 85.
In other words, people die of quote unquote old age.
That's what dying of old ages is basically the body
as a whole becomes so broken and dysfunctional
that you get multi organ system failure.
Your body just says no more and it taps out.
And here's the key point.
The actual maximal genetic human lifespan
isn't age 85, it's around 120.
So the real key, if we want to really live longer,
it's not to cure this disease and to cure that disease
and to cure this disease.
It's actually to learn the science around
how do we slow the rate of aging as much as possible
at the cellular level so that we are on average
reaching close to 120 of the maximal
genetically determined human lifespan
as opposed to dying 30 or 40 years sooner
from basically accelerated cellular aging
and dysfunctional metabolic health.
Yeah, so the named disease that the person
may be currently suffering from is just the effect
of the epigenetic choices that that person has made
that is basically breaking down metabolic pathways.
Right.
It's like if you see somebody, you do a blood test
and you determine, oh, you've got high blood pressure
and your blood sugar, your fasting blood sugar
in the morning and hemoglobin A1C levels indicate
that you have type two diabetes.
Okay, let's put you on this blood pressure medication
to normalize your blood pressure.
Let's put you on metformin to normalize your blood sugar.
Okay, we did it.
We got those biomarkers in ranges that says you are not diabetic
or you don't have high blood pressure,
hypertension anymore.
And then we assume that you're healthy,
but you're not healthy.
You're actually, your physiology is still very much
the product of the same lifestyle and environmental inputs
that led to those dysfunctions in the first place.
And if you take drugs to change those numbers a little bit,
that doesn't mean you're healthier.
And it doesn't live longer.
Yeah, I've always told people like taking something
to lower their cholesterol, a stat drug.
You might as well, you'd be healthier.
If you just erase the number of your blood tests
or the cholesterol, you wrote in a number that you wanted to have
and then look at it and say, wow, no, I'm healthy.
You'd actually be healthier doing that
than by taking the drug and having the damage
to the cellular structure of the metabolic pathways
from the drug itself, complicating things worse,
but giving you a false narrative of cholesterol
in a healthy range.
That's ridiculous.
And the logic can be better understood
if for people, because we're so indoctrinated
into this conventional medical paradigm,
a drug for every disease, and where it's assumed
that taking a drug to normalize that biomarker
is, quote unquote, healthier.
All you have to do to realize the fallacy of this model
is to say, well, what if we took a healthy person
and gave them five different drugs, a blood pressure drug,
a blood sugar drug, a drug for whatever other,
things, an anti-depressant, and so on?
Would we expect that healthy person to be healthier
as a result of those inputs or less healthy?
Less healthy.
And this is very obvious that we can expect much more net harm
than good by taking a healthy person
and putting them on several different drugs.
But we assume that taking a disease person
and putting them on the drugs is going to be beneficial.
The reality is, as a generalization,
you look at statin drugs or blood pressure lowering drugs,
there's a specific, maybe sub-demographic
where you could find studies like in people who
have had multiple heart attacks and who
are on the last phase of very close to death
and their body's failing.
Maybe the statin drug extends that demographic's life
longer than it would have.
But the overall body of evidence
shows that statins don't actually extend lifespan
in the vast majority of people who are prescribed statins.
And that general finding extends across most drugs,
most of the core drugs that are supposed
to be lifesaving and extending human lifespan.
Well, I thought when I started teaching these truths
that you're teaching back in the 80s,
it was like you were running into this brick wall of propaganda
by the other side.
And it hasn't changed.
It's gotten worse.
The news cannot even share the truth anymore
because they're their entire ad campaign
of the pharmaceutical companies is sustaining the network.
That's right.
So it is a grassroots effort to try
to re-educate people.
But there is a large percentage of people
that will still run and get a drug
when they think that that's the solve of their problem.
We're doing things all wrong by making
the focus all about studying disease
and then trying to develop drug cures for disease.
Even, again, even if we cured most of those diseases,
it wouldn't make much difference to your lifespan.
What we actually, what most people need to actually
be focused on is creating health.
And interestingly enough, I'd make the argument
that if there's any demographic of people
that really understands that science,
it's the people who have been seeking
to optimize their health and their performance since the time
that they were young, like athletes,
who are constantly experimenting with their physiology
and trying to gain the edge.
It's like how can I optimize my physical performance?
How can I do everything possible to give the right inputs
in terms of nutrition, give the right inputs in terms
of training, give them right inputs in terms of rest,
give the right inputs in terms of recovery
in terms of sleep and circadian rhythm,
in terms of drinking pure water,
in terms of breathing, clean air,
how can I gain the edge over my competition
by optimizing my physiology in every way possible?
And of course, there's a dark side to that,
the use of steroids and dangerous things
that are harmful to health.
But in principle, that body of knowledge,
as distinct and different from the study of disease
and the attempt to reverse disease
and interrupt abnormal pathology with drugs,
I would argue that it's those athletes who have been studying
how to optimize their physiology
that are actually much better equipped.
It's that body of knowledge,
much more so than the study of disease
that's going to add years or decades to your life,
to your lifespan and especially to your health span,
which is the amount of time that you're alive
that you have a highly functional brain and body.
It did most of our list.
I would agree with everything we've just said.
So, and you covered from that athletic world
and having that experiential knowledge
that really drove you and drives continues
to drive your passion.
How would you take somebody who didn't come from that world,
is living a typical American life
having now been diagnosed with whatever disease
and wants to get off their medications.
How do you know, practically deal
with a person like that?
It really helps a lot if someone can start
to see themselves as an athlete.
You don't have to be an athlete, you don't have to do sports,
you don't have to compete against anyone else.
But to the extent that an individual can adopt the mind frame,
that they are training to accomplish some objective,
that they are learning how to optimize their physiology,
their performance in body and brain
and learning the knowledge and the skill sets
and creating the habits that are necessary to do that.
So it's a process, again, of learning knowledge,
skills and behaviors, habits
that has to be systematically integrated
and cultivated in one's life.
And this is obviously we get started with simple things.
Like if somebody has zero experience,
you walk around a grocery store with them
and say, hey, like we shop in the periphery,
if something has a label on it, you probably shouldn't eat it.
By single ingredient foods that don't have a label on it,
they're not wrapped in plastic with a set of nutrition facts.
Like you go into grocery store, buy some carrots,
just buy some lettuce, you know, things that don't have a label,
buy some beef.
It's got one ingredient, beef, you know?
Buy some chicken, buy some seafood, you know,
and start to build that set of knowledge around,
okay, we're gonna start by doing arguably,
probably the single most important thing
that you can do to optimize your health
and live longer and prevent disease.
Eat only whole foods, get processed foods out of your diet.
You start there, you've just building that knowledge
and those skills and those habits
to make the right choices and eat only whole foods.
Regardless of whether you're vegan or paleo or keto
or whatever, just the commitment to eat whole foods
and learning that set of knowledge
and how to shop in a grocery store
will make a massive difference in your health
just by implementing that one simple thing.
And then there's 20 or 50 or 100 things like that
that can be implemented after that initial basic step.
I would summarize what you just said is
that you have to get people to take responsibility.
Absolutely, you know, because we live in a culture
where I am a disease and I'm the victim of a disease,
you know, instead of, I have this array of symptoms
that my doctor has labeled as a named disease
because of my choices in what I have done up to this point.
And getting people to take responsibility,
like an athlete, okay, you're an athlete
and you're gonna perform, it's all up to you.
You know, you can't, a coach isn't gonna make you good.
A coach can only tell you what you have to do to train
what you ultimately are responsible to do
to train to get to that level that you want to be.
And that's really what doctors have taken
that responsibility away from people.
And maybe I'm talking about standards of care
and because they want everybody to have
that co-dependent relationship on them
instead of real doctors which are teachers, coaches,
you know, putting that, you know,
continue to keep the responsibility
out of the patient to do the things
that they need to do to get better.
And it's actually really simple.
It's just that humans have, humans are great
about doing it in lots of other contexts.
We're just masters of not being able to do it with ourselves.
And here's what I mean by that.
If you've got a plant in your house
and you notice that the leaves are starting to brown
or the plant is wilting,
everybody immediately goes well.
Something's clearly off with the inputs.
Either it's not getting the right light,
it's not getting enough water
or maybe it's getting too much water
or the air quality is not great
or the soil quality is not great.
But it's gonna be one of those things.
It's gonna be something about the environmental inputs
because you know that that plant
isn't genetically programmed to wilt
and be diseased and to brown.
We know that it's actually genetically programmed
to be healthy and assuming,
and we know that if it's not healthy,
that means by definition,
essentially it's not getting the right environmental inputs
to express what it's been programmed genetically to do,
which is to express health.
Humans are exactly the same way.
We're programmed genetically,
millions of years of evolution
have programmed us genetically from our ancestors
who had to deal with extremely harsh conditions,
surviving famines and wars and crazy climates
and all kinds of difficult circumstances.
And we are programmed like other creatures on this planet
genetically to express health.
And if we are not expressing health,
particularly if the species,
a large portion of the whole species
in a particular environment is not expressing health,
we need to be able to go something's off
with the environmental inputs.
How can we correct that?
But instead, most people go,
oh my, just for random reasons or bad genetics,
I'm diseased and therefore I need to go to the doctor
to get a drug to fix my disease.
And it's just, you know it's the equivalent of saying
when your plant's browning and wilting,
let's go study the biochemical processes of browning
and the biochemical processes of wilting
and then go to a lab where we engineer drugs
that we can inject into the plant
that interrupt this pathological process of browning
or this pathological process of wilting.
We have convinced ourselves that we're doing something
very sciencey and very sophisticated
but it's actually laughably absurd
when you just look at it in any other context than humans.
Imagine you've got a big lake
with lots of fish that are dying
and fish that are washing up on shore with tumors on them
and fish with brain diseases
and all kinds of weird behaviors
that indicate mental illness
and atherosclerosis in their arteries and so on.
And you go, imagine your biologist studying this
and you get up on stage
and you present to a conference of other biologists
and you say, you know, I think what's going on
is that there's random genetics
that are causing all these diseases
and if these diseases are just occurring for random reasons
and what we should do is study the biochemistry
of each of these diseases
and set up little hospitals on the shore of the lake
to administer drugs to all the sick fish
with this disease and that disease.
I mean, you'd be laughed off the stage
if you presented this kind of thinking.
Any basic biologist knows, oh,
there's something off in the environment, you know?
There's probably something toxic in the lake.
There's some kind of toxicity in the environment
where these fish are not getting what they need
to be in their natural state, which is health, right?
Well, we'd come a long way from that understanding.
You said just with the human race
and of course, there's been a propaganda campaign,
you know, that spends, you know, billions of dollars
a year to educate the masses
that that diseases from a deficiency in a drug.
And we're still fighting that fight.
You just wonder why people can't have their eyes open
to this maybe because so many people are tied
to the pharmaceutical industry
and some financial way also medical monopoly
and some financial way.
I mean, we saw it with this whole quote, quote, quote,
pandemic the last few years
on how people were just bamboozled to believe things
that were nonsense.
And you know, semi arguments with people
that were highly educated in the office building
that I was in prior to this and there were, you know,
highly educated attorneys
that were wondering why I used to wear a mask
and it's like, I can't, you guys can't read articles,
you can't, I just don't get it.
It is a battle of understanding
and getting people to look at life
through a different paradigm.
And it tends to like you to continue
with this grassroots effort
to get people to open up their eyes to this.
Yeah, agreed and I think ultimately
there's just gonna be a bifurcation
of types of people and types of thinking
and some people are going to insist
that the scientific, quote unquote,
the evidence-based, quote unquote way of doing things
is to keep researching disease
and try to find cures for disease.
I don't really wanna talk about disease
and I don't wanna spend decades of my life
trying to understand all the complex, infinitely complex
and constantly, you know, the complexity
is constantly expanding each day
as new articles are published on new intricacies
of the biochemical abnormalities
of each different disease state
because I don't think, I think we're under a delusion,
we're operating in a fantasy that the answer
to living longer lives and healthier lives
lies in that deeper understanding of disease.
It doesn't, so I'm not interested in that anymore
and even playing the natural game
like so many functional medicine practitioners do,
it's certainly noble work to help people
who do have diseases, but I think ultimately
the bifurcation is either you are going to be
in the majority of the population
that disowns any personal responsibility
for your own health outcomes
and says, I've spent seven decades drinking Coca-Cola
and eating donuts and McDonald's come save me
with your drugs from these diseases that I've developed
and you wanna operate in that kind of fantasy
that you think there's going to develop drugs
that are gonna be able to cure you of your diseases
and that therefore you're gonna live decades longer
than you would have otherwise.
Or you're gonna be in what I consider
the much smarter segment of the population that says,
you know what, my health, my health destiny
is a reflection of my habits and the inputs
just like any other plant that I'm taking care of
or animal that I'm taking care of,
it's health, whether it's obese or lean,
whether it has a good mood or not,
whether it's mentally ill or not,
whether it's highly energetic or chronically fatigued,
is a function of the environment and lifestyle inputs.
And I'm going to take responsibility
for my personal environmental and lifestyle inputs
to provide the right inputs so that my genes can express,
properly express health so that my mitochondria
can produce abundant energy so that my brain works well,
so that my hormones and neurotransmitters work well,
so that I live a long and healthy life
as close as possible to the maximally determined,
genetically determined human lifespan of 120.
And then I accept that eventually my organs will fail
and I'll die of old age.
And I think that's the right way of looking at things.
That's the smart way.
Well, we are totally on the same page of that.
I think getting people to accept that personal responsibility
is the key.
It's also the hardest thing to do to get people to do that.
And I do fully agree and I think it's been played out
in the last few years that there is going to be,
there's just a separation of people that some will
and some won't, there's a lot in the middle
that you're trying to convince.
And that's why we're doing these podcasts.
But it's, it is, there's a big group of people,
probably the majority that think this is nonsense
that there's just some magic potion out there
that's going to be the cure-all.
Yeah, that is a living and a lot of life.
So I think for being on, I would love to have you again.
I just know that you are a wealth of knowledge
and I think our listeners would love to hear more from you
because I really would like to get into
and probably be another hour conversation
on what you're doing.
We'll share your information and your web presence
and everything and what you're doing
with your energy information and your program that you have.
But I would love to get in and get dive deep into that
if you'd willing to be on again.
I'd be happy to, yeah, we didn't get a chance
to go into fatigue and energy enhancement.
But suffice it to say if I can add one little bit on that.
I think what we ought to be focused on
and we ought to be measuring and trying to improve
is not focused on studying disease
and this disease and that disease.
It's, and trying to reverse abnormal pathology.
It's actually, what we should be focused on
in measuring are things like energy
and things like resilience and things like mood
and things like physical performance
and mental performance.
We should be measuring those parameters
rather than just doing lab tests to organic acids tests
and blood tests and measuring blood sugar levels
and blood pressure levels and cholesterol levels.
We ought to be measuring these parameters
that actually give us an indication of our health status
way before a disease emerges.
And if we measure that and we know a person's lifestyle habits
and environmental inputs and we match that up
with, okay, what are the more optimal lifestyle
and environmental inputs for the human species?
Okay, now we can start to make changes
that are about creating health rather than waiting
until we get disease and trying to reverse disease.
And I think energy in particular
and how energetic you are, how fatigued you are
is the single best sort of central indicator
of your overall cellular health
that will tell you whether you have healthy physiology or not.
Do you have abundant energy throughout the day
or are you chronically fatigued and brain and body?
That's a really key indicator
and I would absolutely love to be on again
and talk more about that.
I would love to have you.
Thank you so much.
We'll give our listeners all your contact information
or you wouldn't, you are above the knowledge.
Thank you so much for having me, Dr. Connors.
All right, bye-bye.